in last video I started discussing the
Second Great Awakening which was this
era of increased religious fervor
religious conversion and religiously
inspired social action that happened in
the early nineteenth century of the
United States's history so approximately
1790 to 1850 although I'd say the the
height of this time was from about 1820
to 1840 and the Second Great Awakening
involved circuit riders who were
preachers without their own congregation
going out setting up these camp meetings
where they would preach to thousands of
people about a very emotional version of
Christianity this included encouraging
individuals to give up their ways as
sinners and to work for the creation of
heaven on earth but when we think as
historians it's not enough just to say
ok there was an explosion of religion in
American culture in the early 19th
century instead we want to say what
conditions in American life led to this
explosion why did this major cultural
change happen so let's explore some of
what was going on in the early 19th
century that led people to reinterpret
religion as I described in the last
video the Second Great Awakening is part
of this larger web of cultural social
and political movements and economic
movements that are going on in this time
period historians have spent a lot of
time trying to figure out what was going
on in American life that led to the
sudden re-emergence of religious
devotion so let's explore more on this
side of our web and I have two maps for
us to explore here one is a map of the
Erie Canal and this Canal which allowed
Goods and crops and all sorts of things
to be transported from western New York
down to the Port of New York City and
this is kind of the
area we're looking at here if I can make
it a little more obvious so this is a
blow-up of that little region right
there
this canal was completed in 1825 and I
tell you this not just because canals
are awesome although they are but
because the Erie Canal is a really
important moment in what's called the
market revolution now I'll go more into
the market revolution in another video
but what's important about the market
revolution is that it's this time when
how Americans did business and their
social interactions with people that
they did business with really changed a
lot so there are a couple important
aspects of the market revolution one of
these is a revolution in transportation
which includes the invention and slow
expansion of railroads canals like the
Erie Canal steam ships and steamships
let you do things like go the wrong way
up the Mississippi River and look at all
the farmland that leads to this port of
New Orleans here so these new forms of
transportation make it much easier for
farmers and people who produce goods to
get those goods to distant markets so if
you're a farmer here in Buffalo
now instead of only being able to sell
your apples say to people who live
within a certain radius before your
apples go bad you can just put them on a
nice little barge on the Erie Canal and
send them down to New York City within a
number of days likewise if you're
farming wheat in Missouri you don't have
to sell to just people in here you can
now sell to people all the way down in
New Orleans and that means you can also
even sell to people internationally
right these are these are the big ports
New York City Philadelphia Charleston so
as a producer of goods you are not just
part of a small local market you're now
part of an international
market and it also means you're going to
need ways of communicating with people
who are far away like a telegraph for
example but one more anxious aspect of
this new kind of market-based system is
that you're no longer doing business
quite so much with people that you know
so you might correspond only by letter
or by telegram to the main buyer for
your crops and likewise someone who's
buying those crops might only be able to
correspond distantly with the person
who's producing them so this personal
relationship between people who are
exchanging goods and services starts to
erode and that's very anxious for a lot
of people how do you know that the
person on the other end of your
transaction isn't going to con you in
some way you see this a lot in this time
period the United States also starts to
urbanize and there's lots of writing
about how people worry that the people
that they're passing on the street might
be con men or otherwise out to get them
you know in many ways up until this time
the United States had something of a
barter economy if you look at people's
personal Ledger's you know everybody
kept a very detailed log of what they
had given to whom and who they owed what
in an average day somebody might give
you a carton of eggs on credit and you
might spilled a log-cabin for somebody
on credit because there was this mutual
community system of giving and owing
that everyone had a notion could be
enforced at least through social mores
now as people begin dealing distantly
those social mores don't exist and it
makes people really nervous the other
aspects of this market revolution that I
think is pretty important is in this
time period more and more people start
working for wages as opposed to being
subsistence farmers so now in the early
colonial period most people worked as
kind of a family unit various tasks
might be assigned to various family
members but
one way or another everybody worked in
the home now as factories start to
spring up as part of the market
revolution people are going to work for
wages and typically involves a man
leaving the home and the woman remaining
in it so we get what was known as the
cult of domesticity where women are the
guardians of the home and the moral
guardians of their families and men go
out into the cruel world and toil away
for their daily bread so why does that
matter well one reason that it matters
is because people are now no longer
their own bosses
somebody else is the boss of that person
and they only have so much motivation to
get something done right if your whole
family's subsistence depends on you
making sure that you get this crop in on
time you're going to make sure it
happens but if you're just being paid by
the hour to run a spindle at a textile
factory how much money your boss makes
off your labor isn't really your concern
and so there's a lot of anxiety around
making what had been basically a farming
nation into an industrial nation how
does one behave as a worker in a factory
and how does one as a factory owner make
sure that you have a sober intelligent
hard-working but not too rowdy workforce
so both of these innovations the
relationship between buyers and sellers
and distant markets and the relationship
between factory owners and factory
workers create anxiety about how you're
going to know people are good how you're
going to know that people are holding up
their end in society and one way to
promote that is through religion which
tells you not to be a sinner which tells
you to do a good job which tells you to
be a productive member of society and
work for the common good and promote
your moral compass now that's just one
explanation for why the Second Great
Awakening took off in this time period
and you can tell it's kind of a grim one
right in terms of promoting religion
basically to keep people in line but
that's not the
only possible explanation for why the
Second Great Awakening may have happened
there are also a bunch of social changes
in this time period that could be
serious contributors to this explosion
of religion a one of these was just
westward expansion in general so as the
United States moved west the rate of
western expansion really actually
increased at the in this time period so
about 1790 the center of American
population was about here right so think
about both north and south east and west
where people lived if you kind of
totaled them all up and put a dot right
in the middle of where everybody lived
it would just be right here kind of on
the eastern seaboard as everyone's
pretty close to the coast by 1840 the
center of population was way over here
so just think if this is all the people
who had to live there to be on either
side of that line think of how many
people have to be on either side of this
line for the population to have its
center right there
so people have really spread out in this
time period where before there was kind
of this East Coast elite where all the
money was now the market revolution has
meant that people who live along these
byways laver
along rivers and canals and railroads
those towns are going to start having
people in them with some money and so
the middle class expands and the amount
of people who have the vote expands so
it's really a time of expanding
democracy in general both in terms of
wealth and in terms of political power
and so you can see why a religion like
that promoted in the Second Great
Awakening the the Baptist's the
Methodists that said anyone can have a
relationship with God would become more
popular as more and more people started
to kind of take their own fates in their
own hands right this is the time of the
rugged individual a very popular idea
that one you know pulled oneself up by
the bootstraps and that's the pioneering
spirit so very characteristic
American values that went into making a
type of religion with more individuality
with more possibilities for more people
much more popular in this time period
and there's one case of this that I
think is really interesting and it's in
western New York
so in western New York there's the town
of Rochester and Rochester is really
like a boomtown
it's along the Erie Canal as we saw in
the previous map and Rochester becomes
kind of almost the epicenter of new
religious movements in this time period
so within this radius of Rochester
people called this the burned-over
district because there were so many
religious revivals in this time period
that it was like the whole district was
burned over with Hellfire these
preachers coming past and talking about
the apocalypse and so we'll get to
talking more about some of the religious
movements that come out of this but
within just a couple of miles of
Rochester the Oneida community was born
spiritualism which was the religion
that's kind of based around seances was
born the Church of Jesus Christ of
Latter day Saints often called the
Mormons their religion was born outside
Rochester even the shakers were founded
in upstate New York near Albany so I
think it's noteworthy that as new
communities new people are gaining
prominence through the market revolution
along with them comes a new religious
movement and we'll talk more about what
the impact of this new religious
movement was on American society in the
next video